how does one wake up in the morning and
say you know what i kind of want to be a
forensic pathologist how does that
happen
well it did not happen quite like that
talk about the john f k assassination
how did the events take place
there's no question that the warren
commission report is wrong it's absurd
the single bullet theory is a total joke
why is the president of the world bank
on the warren commission
think about it they wanted to make a
move on russia and china
that's intense right there there's a
pruder film where did they go where did
they run to
they ran up to the grassy knoll we're
not conspiratorial
nut bags and theorists the americans who
continue to believe in the word
commission they are in the minority
human nature
we don't have a track record of holding
secrets for too long these people at the
super spook level they have a mindset
that you and i
can't understand if you read this in a
novel you wouldn't believe it
do you agree with anthony fauci's
approach to covet and the lockdowns and
shutdowns and shutting down other
schools child abuse cases physically
have risen
drug abuse deaths have risen suicides
have risen what are you going to keep
closing down in society
then let's pack up the world and go off
to mars the lives that have been
destroyed
the fortunes that have been lost i'm
telling you this is unbelievable
[Music]
my guest today is dr cyril wecht
probably one of the most
legendary american forensic pathologists
but some would also say controversial
because he was one the first that came
out
in 1965 he presented a paper critiquing
the warren commission to the meeting of
the american academy of forensic
sciences
which not a lot of people were happy
about that in 1972
he became the first civilian ever given
permission to examine the kennedy
assassination
evidence and aside from that he has
commented he was
became famous when we went on tv and he
started giving his opinion and his
thoughts on
rfk assassination mlk he worked on elvis
he's worked on a lot of different uh
assignments 21 000 autopsies that he
personally did
and 41 000 plus that he signed off and
he supervised
so with that being said dr thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
good morning patrick it's a pleasure
thank you for having invited me
before we get into a lot of these topics
and what you've experienced is
how does one wake up in the morning and
say you know what i kind of want to be a
forensic pathologist how does that
happen
well it did not happen quite like that i
went to medical school and um
i had begun to think in my third year of
medical school
combining law and medicine because i
became
infatuated with the activities that
occurred
at the interface of law and medicine and
then i proceeded
along those lines by enrolling in law
school
which i attended while i was doing a
full-time residency in pathology
two years at the va hospital here in
pittsburgh two years as a captain in the
united states air force
and then i decided i wanted to do
forensic pathology
along that way and i did my fifth year
as a fellow
in forensic pathology research fellow
and associate pathologist
at the maryland medical examiner's
office in baltimore
and finished my third year of law school
that evening so it evolved in that
fashion
i decided that the most
important area of medical
forensic science activities occurred
in the field of forensic pathology and
so far as the combining of law and
medicine is concerned
was there what was there an event that
kind of
lit you up or have you always been a
fiery guy because
you know some of us if something happens
in our lives where
uh uh all of a sudden you go from you
see somebody like this pretty nice guy
you know easy going guy yeah he's a
pretty driven guy but
what the hell happened to him in five
years why is he so lit up and fired up
was there an event that kind of
inspired you um no patrick i guess i've
always been
awesome i
i really think i don't go looking for
trouble but i
address matters that are interesting to
me
and matters in which i become involved
and a lot of people don't like that and
i've paid a price
i've paid a big price deprived of
various honors
um various accolades i've had two really
significant legal trials
filed against me which i had to defend
myself against in the 79-81 in allegheny
county
and then 2006 to 2009 at the federal
level here
with the u.s attorney fbi's office i've
paid a price patrick
um and um no i don't want to sound like
an egotistical pompous ass
but i can't help think about frank
sinatra's great song i did it my way
sometimes i bit off more than i can chew
but i
you know i swallowed it and did it my
way
you know i think a lot of times people
will also give credit to those on who
respects
your track record on how you went about
doing what you did and you
you you know the right people uh have
tremendous respect on
how much you were committed to the truth
i think f lee bailey
one time said that you couldn't be
intimidated
if you faced if somebody faced you with
a sherman tank
is what he said and alan dershowitz said
the alan dershowitz said dr wecht is not
a witness for hire he's a witness for
truth which truth can be pretty scary
nowadays
those comments mean a great deal to me
both of them
are our friends i've worked with both of
them on cases alan dershowitz
in the sunny van buehler case lee bailey
in several cases
and we've remained good friends over the
years to have comments like that
from two people um of that stature
uh they themselves they're quite
controversial obviously
and uh yes maybe what do they say birds
of a flatter
feather flock together is that the
expression yeah
that makes sense so why don't we go into
since we have limited time together i
mean we have a lot of
directions we can go but why don't we go
through
uh uh and talk about the john f k
assassination let's start there and
we'll see based on the kind of time that
we have
uh we'll go into other things so if you
look at the gallup
report a study will show that when it
comes on to the warren commission from
till today it's gone from people who
believe another person was involved okay
how many people people believe another
person was involved and how many people
believe
there was only one man involved right
the percentage was
used to be 29 that one only one man was
involved
then 36 percent then it went to 11
percent 14
today around 60
65 to 70 depending on the year
believe another person was involved it
wasn't just
one man that took out john f kennedy
from your experience have been doing
this for so many years you've written
about it you've talked about it you've
talked about it
here at the you know in dallas to the
jfk music you've been all over the place
and spoken about this
where are you at now with your uh
thoughts on what really happened at the
event and was there one man two man
how did the events take place patrick as
the years have gone by
and more serious scientifically
based studies have been performed and my
opinions
have been solidified corroborated um and
underscored but there's no question that
the warren commission report
is wrong it's absurd the single bullet
theory
is a total joke if this were any other
case
uh a lot of my colleagues would have
joined me including back with the house
select committee on assassinations
forensic pathology panel in 78 would
have joined me
and attacking it but they decided
in some kind of a submissive place of a
placid
and passive fashion to go along uh the
civil bullet theory which holds that
one bullet produced seven wounds and two
men
president kennedy governor john connolly
zigzagged in the air right to left up
and down
um breaking two large bones in this six
foot four big bone texan governor john
connolly
emerged near pristine with a weight loss
of only one and a half percent
the entire copper jacket the lead core
bullet intact
except for a slight deformity at the
base from the impact of the firing
mechanism
that is incredible and if you don't have
a single border theory then you don't
have
a soil assassin but there are many other
studies including neurological
neurosurgical radiological photographic
and acoustical the acoustics evidence uh
itself
is what led the house committee on
assassinations back in 79
when they gave their final report to say
that with all likelihood and great
probability
that there was more to it than a sing
assassin
as people don't know this this is a
bipartisan committee
of the top legislative leaders
democratic and republican
who came to that conclusion and yet
patrick not a
darn thing was done about it absolutely
unbelievable
the acoustic evidence clearly shows and
it was performed by the two top outfits
in america both
baranek and newman out of boston and
weiss and australizing
in queens college new york that
the shots came from both the rear and
the front
and if you look at the reaction to the
people that day in the zapruder film
and talk to people who were there where
did they go where did they run to they
ran up to the grassy knoll
behind the picket fence which is where
the second shooter was
it's all there and then when you study
things as i have done
from a pathological standpoint with
colleagues in radiology
and neurosurgery and neurology you see
um the damage done
to the president's head um by the way
patrick
the what what the doctors that night at
bethesda naval hospital
uh concluded was far different from what
has been
have been observed by a dozen or more
top
surgeons at the parkland hospital in uh
in dallas these texas um
surgeons with no axa grind they describe
what they saw
in terms of the damage to the back of
the president's head the occipital area
uh cerebellar tissue which is that part
of the brain located
and the rear and inferior and all of
this
was found to be intact by humes and
boswell that night
at bethesda humes and boswell career
naval pathologist
i want to emphasize this clearly had
never
done a single gunshot wound autopsy
in their entire careers how does that
offend you
i have said i made this offer countless
times
to anybody you find any country in which
the king president prime minister
premier has been assassinated without
autopsy has not been done
by the top medical legal forensic
apology people
in that country you won't find one
country at all
only in the united states of america
could they have so
so be so emboldened so brazen
so arrogant as they think they can get
away with this well they regrettably
have gotten away with it even though as
you pointed out
in your presentatory question comment
commentary
that the majority of americans have
always
rejected the warren commission report so
i and my colleagues
we're not conspiratorial nut bags and
theorists
the americans who continue to believe in
the warren commission
they are in the minority you know i i
hear you say that and then i talked to
jim jenkins and i had jim jenkins on a
year ago
and maybe a year and a half ago and i'll
never forget what he said
for 50 years he didn't want to come out
and talk about it i said why don't you
want to talk about if you see jim
jenkins he's a very
quiet to himself his wife is right next
to me and
reserved one about his business left the
business
he says when i was there first of all
two cars came
one of them was with jackie in it but
what jack jackie thought john f
kennedy's body was in the back it wasn't
a completely different car brought him
in and the body came from the back
because jim jenkins was there
and he says when i held the brain that
had already been done an
incision in the brain i was holding
somebody had already
worked on the brain they had already
done something this is jim jenkins
talking about this i said jim if you've
known this for all these years
why haven't you come out and said
anything he says patrick i'm a simple
man and they told me if you're quiet and
you go away they're not going to do
nothing to you
and my wife and i just decided to go
away and not do anything just have a
regular career
and he's still married to the same woman
he was married to at the time
when this event took place so there are
so many people
that agree with you there are so many
people that are aligned with you
what needs to happen like who needs to
come out and
officially say yes there was more than a
single bullet theory there was more than
one person involved
what who needs to come out and say that
for it to become official and do you
think that'll ever happen
well patrick when i was younger i used
to think that it would happen
um now i must say with great
great dismay um but to be realistic
i don't think it's going to happen in my
lifetime whether it will happen
down the road in another decade or two
when
somebody feels that everybody possibly
involved
even the political progeny you know
the children and the grandchildren
politically speaking of everybody
involved
are gone from the scene too maybe
they'll make a move
but they've been able to cover it up and
they have done so now
since 1960 just think that's uh
let's see 37 20 57 years have been able
to cover it up
so as far as who would have to do it it
would have to come now
than from the executive branch of the
government because as i've already
pointed
out the house select committee there you
had the united states congress
coming in with their findings and they
were ignored the family
well once teddy kennedy was gone and
john john was gone
that left only and then robert was gone
that left
only caroline kennedy and i don't i
can't speak for her
or engage in conjecture but obviously
she made a decision
to let it go and not make this a
campaign
for the rest of her life impacting on
her her husband and her children
uh and so that's where we see it don't
you think like
when you sometimes process this and you
know you're you've spent
endless hours on these topics because
this is your world it's like
talking to a guy stephen a smith who he
has had endless debates of who's the
greatest basketball player of all time
lebron james kobe bryant will
chamberlain or
you know michael jordan he's done that
tens of thousands of hours
it's his world you know you can talk to
uh the anderson coopers and the bill
o'reilly's of the world their debates
has been always about politics
but the question i have for you is say
the people that were involved in wanting
to hold it back
as a secret for people to not find out
right there had to have been
five ten people that knew what really
happened
and then the next question becomes those
five to ten people
what are the chances of people being out
of being able to hold the secret
for 50 some years because you're talking
to your wife and you almost kind of want
to tell your wife's going to nag
eventually she's going to say why don't
you tell me
i've been married to you why don't you
trust me and the husband finally says
well babe let me tell you what happened
here's what happened
then the husband dies the wife's talking
to her sister one day she says do you
really know what happened
then the sister goes and tells her
brother and the sister tells seven
people that tells 28 people
then it comes back saying the truth is
here's what really happened
if if there is somebody that had a real
motive that this was a bigger plan than
just a person that shot him
how come no one's come out and leaked it
i mean it's not like
human nature we don't have a track
record to hold on secrets for too long
yes you know you know what i'm saying
yes i know that's a very good
observation that you have set forth well
first of all i believe that the number
of people who made this decision at the
highest level
of the cia and military active or
just recently retired from those
positions
i don't know i think no more than maybe
five or six people
if indeed that many and thereafter um
patrick it was a matter of people doing
things uh
with the limited right to know you know
just do your assignment and
not anybody hang on the second part of
my answer is this
that and it's an excellent excellent
observation question
you have posed and that is as as
difficult as it is
for intelligent people like you and me
to understand this these people
at the super spook level cia
organizations that we don't even know
about
they they have a mindset patrick that
you and i
can't understand when it comes to
keeping a secret
these people you know they they live in
their own world
they are super super patriots they know
what is good for america
they saw america going to hell in a
basket with what kennedy was
doing nationally and internationally
what was happening
across the world and this wasn't going
to be but in any event so they made that
decision
and and that's it and they're gone now
uh patrick they're gone
um did they share this with other people
well
their spouses they're gone too um
they're number one people they're right
hand men and women
they're gone too it's been a lot of time
a lot of years
um and many of my fellow
warren commissioned critic researchers
they're gone mark lane and sylvia maher
and all these people who have written
great books and extensive studies
that they undertook so this is
i i i can't give you a specific answer
obviously
except to say that when you and i think
about how do you keep something tight
how do you keep something to yourself
and
you can't think of it in a normal
fashion the psychology of of
people is just different at that super
super duper spy level and those are the
people that did it
yeah you know it's it's interesting you
say that because for me
i bank on man's temptation to commit
sin i bank on man's
temptation to drink liquor and want to
brag
and take credit i remember one time i
was interviewing the chief disguise
officer who used to work under president
bush and
she made a whole fake face of president
bush and he couldn't believe that this
person looks like
bush she told me she said i said what's
the quality of a good cia agent
she said a great quality of a great cia
agent is somebody that's
extremely confident a lot of swagger
great charisma
great at sales however
he has no desire to take credit for
taking down an empire i said
what a quality how do you find that she
says you don't it's very hard to find
so again for me i'm like you're 83 years
old you're on your deathbed
you're laying there you know something
the world wants to know your grandson is
over there you whisper to little johnny
saying
hey little johnny you're 48 years old
now i just want you to know
here's what happened to jfk don't ever
tell anybody and little johnny's like
let me go write a book about it and
seven million people read about it
that's
that's where i kind of go with that but
let me go a different angle with you so
there's a lot of different concepts by
the way many people call you a
conspiracy theorist but i think you're
very comfortable with that and nowadays
anybody that says there was more than a
single you know
shoot you know just one person involved
you're a single bullet theory you're a
conspiracy theorist but i'm gonna go
through some of these and you tell me
which one of these you give some
credence to
and which one of them you say pat i
don't know if i give a lot of credence
to this
so the grassy knoll you know saying the
fact that
you know the the second shooter uh that
came you know
uh the the you know what is it called um
there was another person it wasn't just
somebody that came there was somebody
from the other side that shot as well so
that one you just said right now there
was a shooter
right so that one is yes you're saying
that when it happened you already said
that that is what i believe and i won't
repeat what i have already said
sure that is all kinds of shown that was
the position
of the other shooter yep the second one
is the black umbrella man you know steve
louis with who
you know he lifted it up and was he
signaling
did he have a bullet that he shot out of
the umbrella maybe he had something that
he did
or he was signaling to another shooter
and then they do the interview with him
afterwards and he says no i just held
the umbrella up because
i'm a conservative republican and i kind
of wanted to distract him and kind of
wanted to
go back and you know highlight and link
it between
him and chamberlain because of the
appeasement etc etc
so do you do you give any credence to
the black umbrella man
i um i am not certain about that
uh it would be an incredibly fortuitous
uh unbelievably synchronized event
if it just happened in that kind of a
fashion at the same time of course
it could have happened in that way i
don't know the black umbrella man
has been looked into and i don't have a
simple straightforward
unequivocal answer to give you i just
wonder if sometimes somebody shows up
and says
i just want you and i was involved and i
wanted to tell you this please keep this
between
like i get regular emails because i'll
interview somebody that's controversial
let's just say you know resemble garvano
okay and then people who are in the mob
will email me and they'll say
please keep this anonymous you will not
know my name but dot
dot dot here's what really happened in
the events with paul castellano and john
gotti i was there
at sparks restaurant et cetera et cetera
they gave me the whole story i wonder if
you got a lot of these emails over the
years here's the third one
mob did it because the mob helped
the kennedys with illinois because he
kind of needed it so they got the mayor
i don't know 7000 dead people voted and
then they were hoping that the kennedys
were going to help with castro and
cuba because maya orlanski was taking a
hit with his hotels in cuba when fidel
came and says you got to get the hell
out of here
and then rfk flips and rfk ends up going
after the family
after the mob and so rfk ended up
feeling guilty the fact that maybe he
was the reason that killed his bob do
you think
uh killed his brother do you think the
mob had a major involvement in the hit
i think the mob had a major involvement
subsequently
to take care of various people beginning
with lee harvey oswald
and jake and jack rubenstein um
jack ruby little jacob rubenstein from
mafia from the age of 17
in chicago i do not believe that the
mafia played
a role in the primary decision to
assassinate the president
because remember what they would be left
with would be robert kennedy
as attorney general uh so where were
they going with that
i do believe there's no question that
they were used to follow up
to get rid of various people after this
happened yes
got it so they were not the lead domino
but they were one of the dominoes needed
they were not the first one that pushed
everything we could not have dared to do
it and
more importantly patrick they did not
have the wherewithal
uh to really undertake this without and
get away with it uh only only the
highest level
of government and that cia military
level
could have uh performed this and gotten
away with it
so so so the then the next one becomes
the government did it the government was
behind it according to biographer philip
shannon he said apparently bobby
kennedy's first suspicion was that it
was some rogue element in the cia
however after meeting with the cia
director john mccone
rfk changed his mind however at the same
time cia leaders were notably angry
with kennedy over the bay of pigs
invasion you mean you we all know this
and the cia spokesperson edward prince
told the nbc while the cia conspiracy
theories make good fodder for movies but
they are pure
fiction thoughts on that i believe when
i say ciaming cia related
whether they were actively involved at
that time whether they recently resigned
remember john allen dulles
was the cia director he was fired by
kennedy following the fire yeah he was
fired
and then he is appointed through the
warren commission and he's the one
who played the major role in the warren
commission justice warren was pretty
busy with the supreme court the two u.s
senators and the two congresswomen are
pretty damn busy
with their congressional duties so who
is running the show there
um alan dulles incredible unbelievable
if you wrote this
if you read this in a novel you wouldn't
believe it yeah very interesting people
were on that by the way you know the
president of the world bank what is he
doing i know obviously gerald ford but
why why is the president of the world
bank
on the warren commission to what does
that have to do with
very interesting people that were
involved in that and you know the
pastor the the the southerners on their
senator
uh russell um uh
and senator long they richard russell jr
they very reluctantly went along at
lbj's insistence and we all know you
know best of all there in texas
what lbj could do with the literal
figurative twisting of the arms not many
people
dared defy lbj so they were so
very that leads me so that leads me to
the last question here
which is when i'm sitting with jim
jenkins i said uh
who benefited the most from
you know john f kennedy being
assassinated who benefited the most
i would ask you i'm curious to know what
you would say who benefited the most
from john f kennedy being assassinated
the people
collectively including their leaders who
who were very unhappy with what kennedy
had done
failed to do with the invasion of cuba
what he was attempting to do with
warming up the cold war with russia
what he was attempting to do to pull our
troops out of vietnam
collectively these people who were very
very distressed
and remember it patrick they were
looking at five more years of john
kennedy
most likely to be followed by eight
years of bobby kennedy thirteen years
is a lifetime in the social political
uh evolution of a country you don't just
sit back this isn't a ball game
and say where we bat up in the ninth
inning of the
third period of the hockey game or the
last half of the hot basketball game
no you got to make your move you know
the 13 years look look what has happened
under trump i don't want to
digress into politics but i'm just
saying like it or not
pro-trump anti-trump look what has been
accomplished
in four years so to say then what would
have been accomplished in 13 more years
of john and robert kennedy to these
people
it was frightening so they're the ones
who benefited
so when you say they say america
they save america so who is the leader
of
they i know it's not proper english what
i'm saying to you so that's where i'm
going so
who is the leader of they at the time i
i'm not sure who was the specific leader
certainly alan dulles figures in there
remember you remember those generals
after world war
ii that wanted to bomb russia right i
mean wanted to go in
and destroy china um you know the
general you know lemay here and admiral
krumlin there
these people think about it americans
have forgotten
this and many americans don't even know
who they were and what was going
on this is what we were dealing with
post world war ii
they wanted to make a move on russia and
china
so so when i asked the jim jenkins
jim jenkins uh answer was two names he
said j edgar hoover
and i asked him a question i said tell
me what you think about
lyndon johnson okay and i have to tell
you he was quiet for
a a good minute i mean he was
uncomfortable when the name lyndon
johnson came
what do you think about when you hear
the name lyndon johnson what do you
think about him
well i i personally do not believe that
johnson was involved
in the plot to kill kennedy i do believe
that he certainly came to know
darn fast and chose not to do anything
about it
um i don't believe that hoover whom i
despised i don't believe
that he was involved in the plot but he
certainly
certainly was the key person in covering
it up already announcing
the day after that weekend that elijah
was a sole assassin
how in the world pastor think of a
murder that occurred in dallas
last week i'll think of a murder that
occurred in pittsburgh i'll think of the
murders that i deal with as a medical
legal consultant
around the country recently the one in
israel and so on
uh it takes time to determine who's
involved
you may think that you know who the
shooter is you may even
know who the shooter is because you saw
him but you don't know
who was behind the shooter you don't
know whether he had anybody else
involved
how is it possible with this shooting
that he already determined hoover by
sunday monday
after the shooting that oswald acted
alone how is that
it's not possible in no way in the world
given the the the might and
armamentarium
and extensive power of the fbi there's
no way he could have ascertained that
so johnson and hoover in my opinion
played the major roles in covering up i
don't believe that they're involved
in the planning to assassinate the
president however many of my colleagues
do feel otherwise many of them do feel
that johnson and hoover
were involved or one of them why don't
you think i mean if
if they did that over the weekend and
they quickly
moved they will move so quickly when you
read the details behind closed doors
i mean lyndon johnson moved very very
quickly to go be announce the president
get the recognition get up there and go
and talk to jackie and
you know impose himself because he never
liked that irish family these mother you
know what
can't wait to get him the hell out of
here there's a lot of dark stuff when
you read about lyndon johnson and here's
john f kennedy who was
enamored loved adored by america by the
world
everybody appreciated him and this
london guy cannot get the kind of love
that he gets but he was way more
ambitious
than john f kennedy let's not forget
that the most ambitious kid in the
kennedy family was the one that died in
war as a pilot
it was never supposed to be john f
kennedy to be president was supposed to
be joseph kennedy
the oldest son to be president so how
did you get so lucky to be president you
never cared about being a president and
you had back problems
my entire life i wanted to be a
president you become the president
and then all of a sudden you move
quickly and you have this power and
authority
why why would all your colleagues and
friends telling you what what's your
reasoning
for not thinking that hoover and johnson
were the ones involved
and they were the leaders of they well
it's an excellent question
and let me say that i am not adamant in
expressing my belief
that they were not involved got it okay
and you know i
i i can readily appreciate understand
and accept
without uh attempting to argue
strenuously against
uh such an allegation that they may well
have been involved you make an excellent
point i
uh i i don't know and i and i despise
hoover
and johnson uh you know i mixed feelings
about he accomplished a great deal
but his personality and the things that
he did
his own personal life and the things
that he did politically and so on
certainly are not to be uh complimented
or accepted passively well i appreciate
that
that's that's uh that's fair enough you
know you you in an interview once said
you don't even know where you think
harvey oswald was the shooter i think
you said
i don't even believe it was him that
even shot
you're right where were you going with
that i don't think you answered the
whole question because the interview
didn't ask you but where were you going
with that
where i'm going with that is i think
that oswald was
set up passing from the very beginning
um and but you know i just want to make
it clear
that my involvement in this over all of
these half the century
years is not to posthumously exonerate
exclupate lee harvey oswald
in fact patrick i always say when i give
this talk you want oswald as a shooter
fine just give me the second shooter
because of the laws
of texas and every state in the country
and under federal government two people
involved uh in the planning execution
cover-up
of a criminal act makes it a conspiracy
so that opens up the door so i don't
really give a damn
about oswald i want to make that clear
but i do believe
that it is so contrived that aj heidel
ordering this piece of junk weapon a
maniker carcano
by mail and then leaving it there uh
conveniently in his uh six four layer
and so on um and remember oswald was
seen
on the second floor getting a bottle of
soda from a machine when the cops were
dashed in
and the supervisor said he's okay he
works here it would have been seconds
the southeast corner to get over to the
northwest corner where the stairwell was
located
and to be down there in a matter of
seconds and so on highly
highly unlikely i really believe you
know going back to the whole thing
two and a half years in russia uh
marrying
the niece of a kgb colonel coming back
not being interrogated i was
interrogated more when i made a
professional trip in 1972 with some
colleagues
to visit with forensic pathologists in
moscow and london two fbi agents came to
my office two days later when i returned
to america
to ask me what i saw what i observed and
so on in a friendly way but they were
interested in knowing my observation
they didn't give a damn about lee harvey
oswald after two and a half years
nah the whole thing was just just just
an incredible setup
uh that's a [ __ ] and you know i have
come to know
and met with maria oswald and i realized
she's a wife and so on but she firmly
adamantly believes
that he had nothing to do with it for
what that's what
interesting what do you think about a
george bush senior
a george bush senior you mean in terms
of this uh
jfk plot yeah and as far as the jfk plot
any involvement like any no no i i do
not believe
that george bush senior was involved no
got it there's
there's a lot of interesting stories
that you get with it that come out i
mean
gallup has a whole list on what
percentages at the top the number one
believe it or not the number one
conspiracy that the american voters
believe in that's got the biggest vote
was it was a mafia organized crime
gangster that's number one that's from
gallup number two is u.s government
federal government
three is cia four is fidel castro from
cuba
then it is five special interest groups
then it's political groups then it's ku
klux klan then it's london
then it's soviet union then it's right
you know it's a very
interesting you know uh why do you think
it's so important for us to know who was
behind us so
why can't the american people just move
on with this
event that took place why can't we just
say folks will never know
just move on why are we so dead set on
wanting to know exactly what happened
at this event who was behind it i
believe
it is important not to ignore and let
this go patrick because
it gets to the heart of what america is
who we are what we're going to be if
something like this can happen
and be covered up in this fashion then
it could happen again um i believe
it's very important not just from a
moral ethical
standpoint um not just to correct
history
but because it gets to the very essence
to the very
core of america and who we are
and what we became and what we could
have been and should have been
and would have been under under uh
john kennedy for another five years i i
just don't think this is something that
you could set aside
and consider yourself to be a serious
earnest true believer in america and
what it stands for
doc do you have kids yes i have four uh
married children 11 and grandchildren
nice i have three i have one on the way
so i'll uh
god willing i'll i'll have the fourth in
the next few months
but uh do you think there are certain
things
that it's better for your kids to never
know where it will be kept between you
and your wife as a secret
an excellent question um i think
aside from things of a very personal
private
nature but otherwise
i want my kids to know and we share
things we're very close
and we get together every sunday night
for a big family dinner i'm fortunate to
have them all
living here in the greater pittsburgh
area and we've been getting together
even through covet from june and july
and we see
individual families uh invariably uh
one or two of them during the week as
well as our sunday night dinners
so we share and discuss things in my
kids
my oldest son is a state supreme court
justice my second son is a neurosurgeon
my third son is director of the serial
age worked institute of forensic science
elijah duquesne university
and my fourth child my only girl
daughter is an obstetrician gynecologist
i'm very proud of them they're very
intelligent um
and uh and uh you know i've spoken and
uh
no we we share we don't keep secrets
that by the way congratulations on on uh
i read about that that was probably the
most impressive thing about you and you
got an incredible resume but that's
probably the most that's probably what
you're most
uh impressed with what you and your wife
have done yeah
proud of uh but you know do you think
the government kind of looks at it and
says listen american people we look at
you guys as our babies
and it's best there are certain things
you shouldn't know about what really
happened you are better off not knowing
the truth do you think that's kind of
how they see
us citizens that you're too small to
know this kind of stuff because you
couldn't handle the truth the whole
scene from
a few good men but done by the leaders
of they
yes and jack nicholson's a great line um
yes patrick
i agree with you completely
unquestionably at that time
uh the people who came to know uh felt
that this would lead to a revolution in
america with what was going on
with the african-american population uh
the voting and civil rights proposals uh
the way americans felt about the vietnam
war and so on
think of all of the groups that emerged
the
chicago seven and elsewhere and the
riots out there
and in california berkeley yes they
definitely
and i think to this day that is the
belief
they know what is best and they decided
that
forget about it it's over and done with
and uh
you know they determine within a matter
of hours hours
through direct phone calls and visits by
our ambassadors
in beijing moscow and havana that it was
not the chinese wasn't the russians
it wasn't the cubans they ascertained
very quickly
that we have met the enemy and he is us
and once they made that determination
that it was us that was it where were we
going with that
where were we going with that yeah
that's that's uh
that's intense right there so as a as a
person who's been an american
uh forensic pathologist for as many
years as you've been practicing 21 000
autopsies
how i don't know your world i'm not in
your world the average person watching
this
matter of fact 99.9999 percent of people
have no clue what you do to be a
pathologist right but
you're in the world how easy is it for
the best of the best
to be able to have a better assessment
on what happens so for example if you
were assigned
to this and you got the phone call that
night they said you know what
call cyril wecht doc come on in you're
holding john f kennedy's brain
how long would it take you to be able to
come out with an assessment to say
no no no guys it's not a single shooter
it's this if you if they got the best of
the best to look at it
what would be the process you would go
through to be able to tell the american
people
folks this is what happened based on my
assessment
and how accurate would that assessment
be patrick
an excellent observation and question in
fact uh
that would have been ascertained two
weeks later when the brain which had
been fixed in formula
to harden to allow it to be sliced like
a hard-boiled egg in cereal sections
was not done not done the brain was
never examined
placed informally they went back look in
the report and you'll see
december 7 serial sections of the brain
are not made
in order to preserve the specimen
preserve the specimen for whom
to jack and kennedy's mantle base for
her grandchildren
for whom was it being preserved how long
would it have taken
and and your question also gets into
another area
the top forensic apologist and thank you
for your compliment
they were available dr milton helper who
was the dean of forensic apologists in
america
he already packed his bag and i know i
got
he already had his bag packed that's all
certainly already made some phone calls
to a couple of colleagues all of whom
were within one hour driving and flying
time
in washington dc in philadelphia
richmond virginia
boston uh right there uh
to go and work with him on this case
there was no question
uh that they were gonna be called in as
i said earlier in your program
who would do this autopsy and that was
the cover-up
how long would it have taken upon the
gross examination
and talking with the doctors in dallas
they would have already had a pretty
damn good idea
at that point and when they would have
examined the brain two weeks later they
would have seen
the two different hemorrhagic tracts
showing runes from the front
and the back and that is why the brain
was never examined
i discovered that in 1972 when i was the
person on government related
non-government supported
principles given access to the jfk
materials
page one new york times august 24 1972
fred graham their top reporter had that
story um
uh special because he had helped me and
get in there
uh by pushing when they were holding
back and letting me in
and so there it is and the president's
brain as you and i speak here today
um remains missing and for
that's that's uh uh in infuriating to
say the least
to to know that we have access to the
best of the best and we're not making
those phone calls and those resources
and you're the federal government
make the phone call people want to know
what's the big deal
hour away to get somebody like that in
the room andrew let me make another
point
if that were to happen in the case
against mr x is a routine murder case in
dallas or mr y here in pittsburgh
and the the prosecution and the local
medical examiner coroner
had you know deliberately malevolently
or or negligently gotten rid of the
brain and the defense was that hey
there's a two other shooters or another
shooter and so on you want to know
something
that case would be thrown out it would
not proceed to trial
destruction of evidence explanation
of evidence it is called the case would
have been thrown out
i'm telling you this is unbelievable
it's insane when you think about that
and
see i've done so many interviews on this
topic and the deeper i get the more
annoyed i get because
uh uh a lack of you know
in in times of crisis you learn a lot
about leadership right you
you you i'm in iran i'm a kid we're
getting bombed down 167 times in a day
by saddam hussein i'm in tehran i'm
my dad puts us under the stairs because
they would always tell us hide under the
stairs is me my mom my dad my sister
and i'm looking at my dad and my dad's
comp saying everything's gonna be all
right and we're i'm just hearing these
whistling sounds i said this guy's a
leader
i'll follow this guy right i want to be
like my dad when i grow up and we go to
all these other places and we eventually
make it to america i'm in the u.s army
you have different types of things that
happens and you see
and you say wow that guy's a freaking
leader and the guy at this that he's a
great leader he ends up becoming the
delta iv serves 20 years goes to secret
does incredible stuff we're still
friends till today and i just had a
conversation together yesterday
in situations like this this is ultimate
crisis
you know we haven't had the 50
presidents being assassinated we haven't
had 50 presidents period this has only
happened a couple times
how do you make those decisions and the
judgment to not make those phone calls i
have no idea
i would love to have
have had a conversation with the leader
of day you know i would love to know who
the leader of day was
i think for me you know i am more
curious about who's the leader of they
then i'm curious about who the second
shooter was i'm not concerned about the
second shooter
i'm curious who yeah that's what i want
to know yeah
he was just an employee you want to find
out who the employer was
absolutely yeah so look with the limited
time that we got the last topic i want
to talk about is you wrote something in
may 14
2020 about the covet 19 and you just
talked about it here right now saying
every sunday we get together with the
family in pittsburgh we're right next to
each other we have dinner et cetera et
cetera or even during covid
so that means you have more than 10
people in the house if you're doing that
here's 21 people in violation of the
governor's order that's right so i'm
going to read this i'm going to read
this and i'm going to turn it over to
you where you can share your thoughts on
this
as a physician specializing in forensic
pathology i'm only going to read two
paragraphs not the whole thing
i am well aware the importance of
preventative health care measures and
the tragedy of death and every one of
the 21 000 autopsies that have performed
in the last
63 years i've always thought about the
descendant's life and what the
significance of that death is likely to
have been to the family
friends and society however at the same
time as a sensitive and caring human
being husband father and
grandparent i'm also very much aware of
what it means to be alive enjoying
appreciating being with the family and
friends accordingly i am rather
puzzled by the limited amount of
coverage that have noted in the four
daily newspapers
that i receive regarding what the the uh
uh regarding what the effects are among
the living as a result of the
covenanting pandemic and what i consider
to be
degree of hysteria and panic that has
developed an association with the viral
phenomenon
can you can you unpack that for the rest
of us yes
in today's new york times there's a
report about a 24
increase in um mental health problems
among children between the ages of 5 and
that since this covenant locked on child
abuse cases physically have risen
drug abuse deaths have risen suicides
have risen
and that's before you in domestic
situations you can imagine
being locked up as a woman with a root
for a husband and a father with the
children for nine months
what that must be like think of all the
millions of lies that have been
destroyed
the thousands of people who line up in
their cars to get a box of food
millions of children going to bed hungry
every day and so on
think about it those numbers of
morbidity and mortality
far exceed the number of people who have
died from covet
and the number of people who have died
from covet that number is vastly
inflated
when you die in a hospital and you have
strokes and multiple
myocardial infarctions heart attacks
metastatic tumor and so on
but then you acquire covet in the final
days
they signed your death eye as covet i do
not believe the lockdowns
for people under the age of 60 and
certainly in
among children at elementary and high
school in college
and postgraduate level should have been
done i think that should not have
occurred
people who needed protection should have
gotten the utmost degree of protection
in nursing homes elderly disabled people
who suffer from chronic ailments and so
on these people have to be very careful
indeed
and they have to be the recipients of
the best possible care
and preventive medical measures that can
be undertaken but to have locked down
as we have done and the lives that have
been destroyed
the fortunes that have been lost and you
know this is going to be played out
we're not we haven't seen the end of
this yet
uh i think this is far far in excess
i think that a great degree of panic and
hysteria set in
the situation also became markedly
politicized
um and and putting those together and
you have
the debacle of the great tragedies that
exist today
now i think it's important for the
audience to know you're you're a
and you may correct me on this you're
are you a registered independent or
registered democrat
i'm a registered democrat and you're a
registered democrat and you're saying
this so it's not like you're given a
political message you're just giving an
exact
family i'm not a i'm not a trump uh
right that's that's
that's the point because uh by the way
have you had covet yet yourself or no
no i'm getting a vaccine uh next week uh
because i do coroner work
oh autopsies um no i haven't are you not
scared
why are you not scared you're having
dinner how come you're not concerned
about it no no no no it's not that you
know i
brazen and vote um uh when i go into a
store where i have to wear a mask i do
but you know i don't wear a mask here in
my office i don't wear a mask when our
family
21 gets together we don't sit there with
masks and so on and i said
two of my um kids are are doctors
and so on i don't know this everybody
has to deal with it the way
that they feel they're comfortable with
um
and uh you know the mask brigaders as i
call them
uh fine they they want to save lives
and somehow they are unmindful totally
unmindful of
all the lives that they are costing
because of their
very exalted endeavors do you agree with
anthony fauci's approach to covet and
the lockdowns and shutdowns and shutting
down
of the schools etc etc would you have a
different perspective than which fauci's
done
no i admire and respect dr farci whom i
met with uh many years ago
at a private dinner in washington dc
through a mutual friend
and so on i think he's a great man
however i disagree
as i've already said with these total
lockdowns
and by the way you know i'm not alone
there are a lot of scientific studies i
just read one from israel
signed off by a hundred top scientists
including
nobel laureates and so on and a lot of
people uh
who are questioning uh these things
about the mask
and the and the lockdowns and so on you
know we have to deal with these things
we dealt with
aids and ebola and and
and we're dealing with flu and so on the
death rate from flu and pneumonia every
year
exchange the death rate from covet you
deal with these things
and pastor we're going to have other
regrettable epidemics like this
are there going to be you think this is
the end no more will there be viruses
whether they come from china or
elsewhere no of course it's going to
happen again
so what are you going to keep closing
down society then let's pack up the
world and go off to mars
why so your approach is there's no need
to shut down and go through the approach
that we went through you say you leave
the economy open leave the businesses
open
let's just make sure we're a little bit
more cautious about ourselves and so we
don't spread this and we don't get this
yes i think we've learned some things
too since then washing our hands and not
coughing and
breathing and sitting at a bar and uh
and
uh and spitting on the guy next to you
and saying yeah we've learned
and we should follow those things
absolutely i wish i had a few hours with
you i really enjoyed it
i wish you are a great interviewer and i
i would love it i apologize i wish i had
more time
and maybe we can get together again
patrick um i definitely look forward to
it your wisdom is definitely appreciated
by me and i hope the audience enjoyed
you as much as i did i hope that they'll
find a way to get my book to
the life and deaths of cyrillic memoirs
of america's most controversial forensic
colleges available through amazon i hope
that they'll get that
read about some of my cases learn about
my own travails and trials
with the criminal justice system and
learn about other things of great
interest please
we will always put the link of the book
below and i typically do video after
this to get everyone to buy your book
but yes we will definitely put the link
below
for folks to get with that being said
thank you so much thank you very much
i appreciate the opportunity been a
great pleasure
talking with you you're wonderful thank
you thank you
different kind of a conversation right
when you hear somebody like this 21 000
autopsies the experience is 41 000 he's
supervised and seen imagine where he's
coming from a democrat
saying his belief system how he's just
telling the truth
here's how i feel about this crazy i
love interviewing people like this who
are willing to challenge their own
position and anybody else's position
because what they're solving for is the
truth
and unfortunately in times like this
people who are seeking the truth
sometimes get uh
criticized like he has so anyways i hope
you enjoyed the interview i did
i'd like to know what you took away from
it if you haven't ordered this book
click on the link below and if you
enjoyed this interview i got another one
i did with jim jenkins which for
whatever reason
the day we went live with the jim
jenkins interview he was one of the
first people that held
john f kennedy's brain at 21 years old
when he tells a story
about the assassination in the autopsy
room i mean i
you are gonna want to hear his
perspective on this if you've not
watched it
click over here to watch the full
interview and then when you watch this
interview tell me what you took away
from this
whether you comment in the video or send
me a tweet directly at patrickbetdavid
because i want to hear from you
regarding the topic of jfk assassination
thank you everyone bye-bye
[Music]